all the actual information was at the
edges it wasn't coming from the center
it was all at the edges it's kind of
like jordan hall talks about like you
know that
the the that's the great part of the
internet so so i found
all the value i had was from listening
to people like robert malone and peter
mccullough and and yourself and and um
pierre cory and all the flcc doctors
paul merrick and on and on and on these
were people who who they didn't always
get it right but i could tell that they
were
intensively caring about trying to get
it right um
and so it was amazing that way but i'm
wondering um
like what was the cost to you
because you you in many ways took way
more slings and arrows than i did um you
know you paid some prices i don't know
whether i should talk about this
publicly or not but i'm going to do it
um
this has been a process
of
the creation of anti-fragility
and the stuff that was pointed at
heather and me was
it was incredibly
difficult i mean the just the simple
volume of it at its worst was
there was no way to grapple with it
right you just knew that there were
vile slanders being delivered that you'd
never even know were said because you
just couldn't even look at it all even
if that was your instinct so
um it was very unpleasant
it was also not our first rodeo
and so
there's a way in which yeah this one was
the worst one i've ever seen by far
but there was also
an awareness that there's a process to
it and that one gets through that and
the point is live to fight another day
and this process actually makes you
stronger in the end
so there were moments at which i doubted
that and i mean i still do i still
wonder if
the
um
[Music]
the vindication of all of the points
that have been correct is going to be
buried
specifically for the purpose of
preventing uh
me and and others like you from speaking
up again in the face of the next one
right
so i know that the thing is still very
interested
in capitalizing
on the progress that it made
psychologically
i also know from talking to people that
people have a
very wrong impression
of where we currently are in other words
they directed at this incredible
onslaught at us and it was
uh
i don't even have the words for
what it was like it was just like you
know it was a fire hose of awful
but
in the end we are now in the position of
watching this large this ever-growing
population of people
recognize who was trying
to warn them
and who was actively steering them into
danger and that is incredibly gratifying
so
um
it was bad but every time they do this
and they leave us standing we get
stronger that's the thing
so
so you had some dark days but you but
you you'd been there before so you kind
of knew what was coming or did you ever
lose hope like that oh my god yeah i
mean i still i still worry about that um
but
again
a i think that we are at a point where
the scale of the disasters is is now so
great
that in effect they have tied our hands
right we might as well fight
right because the solution of not
fighting that's going to be a short ride
so
we have to fight that would have been my
inclination and i know your inclination
also
and yeah they created some dark days but
in the end i'm not
at all convinced they didn't
their plan didn't backfire
and that they didn't you know
let's put it this way i told people who
were close to me back when the lab leak
story broke right and of course nobody
has formally acknowledged that this is
what happened but we all know that the
evidence has gotten stronger and
stronger
i told them look
that was a surprise win
i didn't think we were going to win that
one i knew we had to fight it but i
didn't think we were going to win
having won it there are now two others
right there's the question of early
treatment
and there's the question of vaccine
safety and efficacy
if the public wakes up on all three of
those fronts
suddenly we now know something
we know
that the following systems
have completely failed to protect us and
in fact have steered us into greater
danger
the academy
the press
big tech
the public health apparatus and all of
the governmental structures it is
plugged into
that is an amazing across-the-board
failure
and
no one who is paying attention could
possibly look at a failure of all of
those things
and come away with the impression
that anything small could possibly put
us back on track
so
the reason
that we put ourselves in danger
in this case
was that
there's a process i described which is
that certain stories diagnosed the
system
right the evergreen story diagnosed the
press
right
part of the press couldn't report it
because it went in the wrong direction
for their audience and another part of
the press could report it and so it
revealed this process of like everybody
can report the stories about the other
side and they don't report the stories
about their own side so the new york
times completely [ __ ] it up well they
have [ __ ] it up there were people on
the editorial page but never mind the
point is
and across the board failure as we have
seen with covid is a dire emergency
having nothing to do with covid
pandemics drugs vaccines anything it is
a dire
dire failure of the systems on which we
are depending
and my hope is
that this failure having been
revealed at great cost to many of us now
allows us to have the conversation we
need to have which is the same one that
you raised about the insects and their
collapse right we are
screwing up the things on which we
depend and that is a suicidal thing to
do
so
i don't know uh
i'm hopeful and you know before we close
this out we should talk about this march
that is upcoming tomorrow which you and
i both have a relationship with but
neither of us will be at
but i think we are at that moment where
the system has revealed itself and i
don't know that in our lifetimes we will
get a better opportunity to have the
conversation we need to have about
civilizational collapse which is looming
because these systems have stopped doing
what they're supposed to do
[Music]